hey was someone named Samuel leaves and
I want to share something with you that
I've been holding back and to be honest
this I'm scared of but it's changing
everything everything is changing I'm
scared to put this out there I've been
teaching for the last five years and
been doing for the last ten years
property investment you know that lease
option agreement spy refurbish refinance
rents around dealing with motivated
sellers working at the return on
investment didn't buy to let all that
stuff and there's an app that someone
created which is basically I don't know
if this has made a lot of things
redundant deal saucers but they've
created an app and to be honest the guy
who made this app okay Ashley woodland
and his partner okay cool guys when they
told me that they were creating this app
or I didn't believe them and I actually
I don't laugh at them but I was like
that will never happen and now I
couldn't earn my property business
without this app and Ashley woodland
probably thinks I came into my office
and he showed me the friggin app he said
Samuel there's the app and I was looking
at the app I was looking at the app and
I was just like in disbelief
and I'm gonna tell you I'm going to tell
you something honest okay I don't even
told Ashley this when I saw this app it
freaked me out as pleased as I was that
it would save me time I've spent years
learning how to find properties on
Rightmove that are in negative equity
this app just does it for you I spent
years searching through Rightmove and
figuring out how to work out the return
on investment on a property deal this
app every single property online I'm
right with you just it just tells you
the return on investment it works it out
every single HMO a potential HMO banging
there every single motivated set it just
and I'm going to tell you the truth okay
I'm going to be available right now
when he showed me the app it annoyed me
very badly because I thought I've
learned these skills I figured out how
to do this the app has made me redundant
the app is gonna make everybody else be
able to do what I've worked hard to be
able to do all my students are gonna
suddenly bang like and I'm being really
honest now I didn't want the app to be
recognized I was just thinking if the
app scared me how can how can it just
work out the return on investment I was
trying to think of a reason to discredit
the app I was like now and I was trying
to find a problem with it and it was so
freaking good then I got pissed off that
I didn't create the app first cuz I had
the same idea I had the same idea and it
reminded me of you know those people
though like I had that idea I was that
person I had that idea so I decided with
Ashley I just said to him dude I admit
the apps great ok well done it finds
hate channels it works out the return on
investment negative equity refurb
opportunities by refurbish refine and
opportunities it gives you all the
friggin sheets it's great
ok it's great but let me partner with
you so what did I do
I got some shares in the app so that's
my disclaimer now the app belongs partly
just partly to me
and at least that way I don't feel so
discontent so anyway I just wanted to do
a video about this and share it I'm
loving it right move is dead this app is
on fire and to be honest I'm still kind
of feeling angry about it in a way I'm
just emotional about this app ok I just
I mean look look at this look at what it
shows you hate gemo and then here are
all the HMOs in any area you want look
by Gillette and you can just see the
return on investment negative equity
leads do you know how long I spent
busting my ass off to find negative
equity leads now you can just to the
property investor that's like
Gold Dust anyway you're probably
wondering how many thousands of pounds
you have to invest to be part of this
app and again annoyingly and I've said
this to Ashley it's I don't how much it
it's like I think it's 45 pounds less
than 50 pounds to be able to have access
to this app so I'll leave a link or
maybe even set up a discount code with
my name in it so you can get tiny
discount that's the app Congrats Ashley
and everybody that was involved in
making this app Samuel leads I'm
impressed
I felt like Simon Cowell that said
you'll never be a pop star and now
you're a pop star this is the most
amazing property app I've seen in my
life I'm impressed and if you're a
subscriber of mine and you want to be
able to just be a ninja and hack you
know got all these hacks and have all
the info done for you just just just
disclaimer you still need to do the work
okay this app isn't going to make you
rich what it's going to do is it's just
going to give you all the leads on a
pike feeder then pick up the phone use
your skills and get some deals friggin
love this app get the app folks it's
amazing and it will save you time anyway
I'm gonna get back to find some deals
peace out